ورسوله اللهم صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما صليت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك
حميد
مجيد اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد
كما باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال
ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد
مجيد اما
بعد فما زلنا في فصل من كتاب تهذيب الاماء
واللغات للحافظ النووي
تكمله لما
نقراه من كتاب زاد
المعاد للحافظ شمس
الدين ابن القيم رحمه الله
تعالى في
فصل طال
بنا لكنه فصل ماتع حول معجزات النبي صلى
الله عليه عليه وسلم حول ايات
نبوته وقد وصلنا
الى قريبا من نهايه هذا
الفصل فدرس موصول في
ذلك
زد
المعاد تهذيب الاسماء واللغات الحافظ الن
رحمه
الله زد
المد
المدق محد صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏features his
character and that he wr it while he was
traveling and he wr from
memory and
so there are parts of the book which are
seem to be a little bit out of order and
there are also parts of the book
which are very very
extensive ‏while others
areef and so we
are to from
oneal the
weing
here fin ان شاء الله
تالى
hope صلى الله عليه
وسلم
يقول النووي رحمه الله وقال لازواجه يعني
من ايات
نبوته ما اخبر
به
من ما
سيكون
في
المستقبل فن عليه الصلاه والسلام بشيء من
الغيب بما انباه الله فمن ذلك انه قال
لازواجه
اطولكن
يدا اسرعكن لحاقا بي يعني
موتا وطول اليد هنا يقول النووي فكان كذلك
طول اليد هنا كنايه عن الاعطاء
والانفاق
الصدقه يعني اكثركن
تصدقا
وهذا كما روت عنه ام
المؤمنين رضي الله عنها ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال
لها لا توعي فيوعي الله عليك يعني لا
تدخر
اموالا دون انفاقها
فتخر من الحسنات والثواب عند الله سبحانه
وتعالى عنك
وهي زينب رضي الله عنها زينب بنت جحش وهي
اول نسائه موتا بعده صلى الله عليه وسلم
لحاقا به فقال اطول ك يدا يعني في
الصدقه اسرع كن لحاقا به يعني وفاه فكان
كذلك
ا صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏ored us of things that would happ
in the
future we gone of course through
physical
miracles the splitting of the moon and
different things that physically
happened in present time also we gone
through historical miracles things that
he informed of that happened in the past
that he could not have possibly known on
his own likewise
‏prophetic miracles regarding the future
prophecies
and we been going through many of these
prophecies and giving detail and context
to many of them which has
mentioned one of such prophecies
nra coled bu
معاشه رضي الله
تعالى
عنها prop صل الله عليه وسلم
‏be the first to follow me to suit in
death the first to pass away after me of
my
wies will be the charitable among you
and
that رضي الله
عنها وقال عبد الله بن سلام عبد الله بن
سلام هو ممن بشر بالجنه في الدنيا النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم بشره بالجنه وانزلت
فيه ايات من كتاب الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ايات مما فيها ذكر وثناء على بعض اهل
الكتاب ممن امنوا بالنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
و عبد الله بن سلام رضي الله عنه كان من
اشراف
وعلماء اليهود في المدينه ومن احبار
اليهود فلما قدم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وسمع به وكان ذا شرف وذا
جاهه
جاءه
واخبره ساله بعض الاسئله لا يست يع
الاجابه عنها الا
نبي
فلما اجابها النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بادر بالاسلام وحسن اسلامه وكان مضرب
المثل لمن
اوتي
اجره مرتين من اهل الكتاب م من امنوا من
اهل الكتاب قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
له انت على الاسلام حتى تموت
فكان كذلك هذه الروايه في الصحيحين من
حديث عبد الله بن سلام انت على الاسلام
حتى تموت فلم يرتد عن الاسلام ولم يتولى
على عاقبيه
وانما كان مسلما مجاهدا ساعيا في
الخيرات حتى توفاه الله سبحانه وتعالى على
ذلك
‏another prop was عبد الله بن سلام عبد
الله بن سلام رضي اللهه
one
few
the jewish
schar
مد صلى الله عليه وسلم
arrived in him
there learned jewish
inina
‏wom
them
relent صلى الله عليه
وسلم relented to the validity of his
propet few of them did one of them was
عبدن salam and he is a man who is
the
was par
عبد الله بن سلام was very high status
in med among his he
was عبد اللهن
سلام صل الله عليه
وسلم ‏propet should be able to answer
and when they were answered
heen toing muslim the prop صل الله عليه
وسلم said بخاري مسلم he said عبد اللهن
salam you will be upon islam until your
death you will never islam you will
never from islam or lose interest any of
these things and so said
عبد الله بن
سلام
محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام رضي الله عنه
يقول ودعا لانس بان يكثر
ماله بان يكثر ماله
وولده ويطول عمر فكان كذلك
انس اللي هو انس بن مالك عاش فوق 100 سنه
ولم يكن احد من الانصاري اكثر مالا منه
ودفن من اولاده الذكور
لصلبه 120 ابنا قبل قدوم
الحجاج سوى غيرهم وهذا مصرح به في صحيح
البخاري وغيره هذا متفق عليه بين الم
مرخين انه دفن يعني مات في
حياته
هذا العدد الهائل من ابنائه لصلبه
هذه بعض الناس يستبعد هذا الشيء يعني 120
ولد لصلبه دفن قبل قدوم الحجاج
والحجاج ولي في سنه 60 او 59 50 في هذه
تقريبا في هذا هذه
الفتره
و انس رضي الله عنه كان له 120 ابنا يعني
من الاولاد
دفنهم بنفسه يعني في ماتوا في زمنه في
حياته وذلك انه
كان كان
ابناؤه في ال الجهاد في سبيل الله ومن
المرابطين وكذا والشباب كانوا
يخرجون وينضمون الى جيوش الاسلام في سن
مبكر 14 سنه 15 سنه هذا رجل بالغ يجوز له
ان يساهم في وان
يغزو وكذلك كانت لهم الفتوح وكانت
لهم يعني وكان لهم النصيب الاوفر من
السراري
والازواج والزوجات وما شابه ذلك فلا
يستبعد ان يكثر اولاده بهذا العدد وهذا
امر كما ذكرنا من بركه دعاء النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
له
another
م عليه الصلاه والسلام
انسن مك
سم صل الله عليه
وسلم دعا
ان انس رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم he was
years and st
صلى الله عليه
وسلم
named and
offered as a personal
serv صل الله عليه
وسلم ‏with him and
compl that he would be
completely dedicated to serving the
propet الله عليه وسلم that he needed
is because a child of this age he old
enough to understand
responsibility but not old to he could
not interact with the
propet wife
ان رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم
دعاس الله
‏may you make his offspring
andal
and age
hisan blessed ext exp
hisan and
his انسن مك
over
liv
‏that to us is because he was one of the
last of the companions to pass away some
scholars mention him to be the last
though there others he was the last in
his area
for was
‏was
more
he pal
and
majority of the people of medina they
would harv their crs and their dates
once a
year his crops would yield harvest twice
a year and
heed mean who passed in his life
‏over his own
children and before
الحج انس رضي الله عنه
عراق
الحج الحجاج بن يوسف الثق
[Silence]
عن صلى الله عليه
وسلم
انسن
مال انس بن مالك رضي الله
عنه صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا يقول ودعا صلى
الله عليه وسلم ان يعز الله الاسلام بعمر
بن الخطاب او بابي جهل فاعزك الله بعمر
رضي الله عنه هذه الروايه موجوده في جامع
الترمذي ومسند الامام
احمد
واسناده فيه
مقال الا انه حديث حسن ومشهور بين علماء
السيره ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم دعا
بان يعز الله سبحانه وتعالى الاسلام
ب عمر بن الخطاب او ابي جهل وكان يقال له
ابي
الحكم اما
بعمر
او هشام بن
عمر فعز الله سبحانه وتعالى الاسلام
بعمر حتى ان اكثر الصحابه في زمنه كانوا
يخفون اسلامهم الا عمر عمر بعد ان اسلم
خرج في طرقات مكه وجاء بيت
وباب ابي جهل واعلن اسلامه وارغم الله
سبحانه وتعالى به
انوف من عاد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وخرج اكثر الصحابه ا الى المدينه
خلسه ليلا و متخفين الا عمر عمر هاجر
علانيه وتحدى ان يقف في طريقه احد هو
وحمزه ابن عبد المطلب رضي الله تعالى
عنه صلى الله عليه
وسلم دعا الله سبحانه وتعالى ‏that
الله gr the
musl
strength with اسلام of عمر
or
عمر ابو
جهل so made that one of them musim
andes seem could
lik but you
عمرن
الخطب ابو
جهل is a mirle because these the last
two human being in all
of anyone would expect to accept اسلام
عمرن
الخطب
‏was
for the صل الله عليه
وسلم
was
po and
was صلى الله عليه
وسلم he was also to
enjoying ‏weak muslim slaves and
torturing them is how he would this was
his this is how incredibly oppressive he
was to the muslims at that
time the idea the
notion
that muslim at that time was just short
of
absurd just as unreasonable as it is in
our minds now
‏wasely صل الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى عمن الخب
not
الله سبحانه
وتالى
حجج all صل الله عليه وسلم time
حرده 11 12
year
and
خه second خه صل الله عليه
وسلم عمرن الخب رضي الله عنه
persia places in europe r roman
empire was in his time thean empire in
his time
‏also the those
differents the
time عمر رضي الله
عنه
egy
all صل الله عمر رضي الله
عنه يقول النووي ودع على سراقه ابن مالك
فارتطمت به فرسه في جلد من الارض وساخت
قوائمها فيها فناداه بالامان وساله الدعاء
له هذه الروايه في البخاري وقد سبق
لنا قصه قصه سراقه رضي الله عنه وهو لم
يسلم وقت اذ وانما
اسلم في عام الفتح عند فتح مكه وكانت له
وولات وجولات وكان
له كان له اليط
الحسن في الاسلام خاصه في زمن عمر رضي
الله عنه فكان من عظماء
الصحابه
another سراقه ابن
مالك سراقه ابن مالك رضي الله عنه ‏in
great deta as matter we an
entire discussing the history of ابن مك
سن مك ملم in year conquest of
مه صلى الله عليه وسلم
حجره
m there was a number of things that
happen between him and
صلى الله عليه
وسلم ودعا لعلي رضي الله عنه ان يذهب الله
عنه الحر
والبرد فلم يكن يجد حرا ولا
بردا هذه الروايه موجوده عند ابن ماجه في
سننه
وضعف اسناد هذه الروايه البصيري وفش ذكر
هذا الامر في كتب
السيره
الله دعا علي علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله تع
عنه
success
first
دعا
علي
‏was علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله
عنه
دعاء ودعا لحذيفه ليله بعثه ان ياتي بخبر
الاحزاب الا يجد بردا فلم يجده حتى رجع
هذه الروايه موجوده عند مسلم في صحيحه
وهذا في غزوه الاحزاب ان النبي صلى الله
عليه
وسلم طلب من الصحابه
احدا
يخرج ليلا في برد شديد وخوف
هائل فينظر
احوال
الاحزاب
وبالذات ابي سفيان
وغيره
ف جاء الاختيار على حذيفه رضي الله عنه
وكان من البرد لابس
من كل الملابس اللي في البيت يعني حتى
بعض الامور التي تلفح بها زوجته كان اخذها
من شده
البرد
ف كان في خوف شديد وبرد شديد فالنبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وقع اختياره على
حذيفه والصحابه هو سالهم من ياتينا بخبر
القوم وله
الجنه ولا واحد رفع ايده من
الخوف خوف وبلغت القلوب والحناجر
كان خوف
شديد هذا ما في عيب هذا شيء حدث بل حدث
حذيفه رضي الله الله عنه بهذه القصه لما
كان بعض التابعين يعني يتبجح ويقول لو كنت
في زمن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لفعلت فقال
حذيفه ما
يدريك انا كنت في هذا الموقف موجود عمر
ابو بكر وعمر ولا واحد رفع ايدهه من
الخوف لكن وقع اختياره صلى الله عليه وسلم
على حذ
فدعا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
له
الا يشعر
بالبرد الخوف بقي ان الجنه سلعه
غاليه
ف لكن البرد اراحه الله سبحانه وتعالى
منه فخرج فنظر ابا سفيان والنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم امره
الا يتدخل في القوم بس انظر اخبارهم وارجع
فهو راى ابا
سفيان وظهره الى النار من شده
البرد فكاد ان
يقتله واستطاع ان يفعل لكن تذكر امر النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاحم وعاد وبعد ان عاد رجع يشعر بالبرد
هذه عند الامام مسلم في صحيحه في قصه
طويله حذيفه رضي الله
عنه
حذيفه b of
confed b
trch
was
days the
‏tri
ar
jew
trfe prop الله عليه
وسلم
ands and to snuff out as theirs snu out
isam completely once and for
all was a very very night and it was
incredi frightening night
صلى الله عليه وسلم
حه
and tell him position var troops and
what they were up to and
so was so that he had some
of the clothing or some of the garments
of his wife wrapped around his hands
wrapped around his neck his face
his صل الله عليه
وسلعا حذيفه رضي
عنه
دعا صحيح مسلم ودع لابن عباس ان يفقهه
الله في الدين فكان كذلك النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم دعا لابن عباس
كما في
الصحيحين اللهم فقهه في الدين وزاد الطبري
وعلمه التاويل يعني تاويل
القران ف كان معروفا ابن عباس رضي الله
تعالى عنه عن ابي بعلمه الواسع الغزير
وبعلو كعبه في
العلوم الشرعيه بشكل عام وبتفسير القران
بشكل
خاص حتى انه كان يطلق عليه في زمن ابن
مسعود كان ابن مسعود رضي الله عنه
نفسه يمدح ابن عباس وابن مسعود من كبار
الصحابه اب مسعود هاجر الهجره الاولى كان
ابن عباس ما انولد لسه لما كان ابن مسعود
صحابي
لكن ابن مسعود على علو كعبه في العلم
و على الرغم من جلالته في
التفسير كان يقول ما اعلم احدا اعلم من
ابن عباس
في كتاب الله وكان يلقب بترجمان
القران
وجاءته
كذلك تزكيه من علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله
عنه حتى قيل ان ابن
عباس ذهب وام الحج وفسر سوره النور وقيل
غيرها في خطبته لو سمعها فارس والروم
لاسلم
من دقه نظره
ووسع علمه في كتاب الله فكان يلقب ابن
عباس بالحبر البحر الحبر البحر وترجمان
القران وحبر الامه وهذا
ببركه دعاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم له
على الرغم انه اكثر ما اخذ لم ياخذه عن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مباشره انه كان
صغير حتى بعض العلماء ونقل
هذا السخاوي رحمه الله في شرحه على الفيه
العراق في الحديث في مصطلح الحديث فتح
المغيث
ينقل عن
المحدثين انهم
عدوا الاحاديث التي يرويها ابن
عباس عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مما سمع
عنه مباشره بدون
واسطه وهي تاتي تقريبا الى 14 حديث فقط مع
انه ابن عباس هو من
العبادله يعني
ابن عبد الله بن عمر و عبد الله بن مسعود
وعبد الله بن عمر وعبد الله بن عباس هذول
العبادله هذول يرمون اكثر الروايات هؤلاء
من السبعه الذين
روايتهم اكثر من احد اكثر الصحابه روايه
فابن عباس طلب العلم من الصحابه من كبار
الصحابه
و
ادرك رضي الله تعالى عنه بالرغم انه
لم يكن كبيرا بالغ في زمن النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم توف
وابن عباس تقريبا 13 او 14 سنه كان صغيرا
ويروي القليل عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
مما
سمعه مباشره او راه
لكن اصبح حبر الامه وذلك ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم دعا له اللهم فقهه في
الدين وعلمه التاويل فكان
كذلك
‏another mir صلى الله عليه
وسلمن
عباس ابن
عباس رضي الله عنه ابن
عس صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏was اسرا
معراج الاسراء
والمعراج
حجج in the
most aged
ع صل الله عليه
وسلم
was3
14 صلى الله عليه وسلم ح
الودا and so you can how he was and how
much time
صل الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم he ع son ع hadn't even musim yet
when the prop صل الله عليه
وسلم
ag ma of
theat
صل الله عليه
وسلم مر
الصحي
حث
عس الله عليه
وسلم
العجره to مدين was حج was عا
الفتح صلى الله عليه وسلم لاجره بعد
الفتح ابن
عس
مد ‏he was was3 years صلى الله عليه وسلم
passed
so he is the ofite of the propet الله
عليه
وسلم made
him الله سبحانه وتعالى
te great of islam in general and exes of
qur
تيرر تير
قرقران
was ابن عس رضي الله عنه و
عني
stud مدرسه مه مدرسه ابن عس رضي الله
عنهما
are تبعين regard تير
قران ابن
مسعود علي بني طالب رضي الله
عنه
ع
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان شاء الله
fin ضان ان شاء
الله رمضان نكتفي بهذا القدر اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين اكبر الله
اكبر